Today's topic. All right. So I'm gonna read out a story for you today,
cuz this is a great story. Oh, story times. Nice.
My ex got his act together after we divorced my husband and I were together for
10 years, married for six, no kids. We eventually grew apart.
And that is to say, I grew up and he didn't.
He wanted to live the life of a teenager, willing to his thirties. The last two,
three years together were horrible. After his dad passed away,
he gained all his weight, lost his job. I tried to help him support him,
but he would just wallow himself pity and stopped pitching in around the house.
He spent all his free time smoking weed and being around on the computer.
Mm-hmm <affirmative> he had to sell his junk card at pay your bills eventually h
ad enough and we got a divorce in 2015 were essentially been
no contact since it was finalized.
Last Friday,
I happened to bump into him downtown and he's completely different person.
He lost all the weight he put on. Had actually toned up some.
He was wearing a tailored suit.
He had an ill fitting one for weddings and funerals while we were together.
It's a little petty and he had a nice watch.
He may have gotten hair plugs or something because his thinning hair wasn't as
pronounced.
As before he told me he bought a condo nearby within walking distance of his new
job, a well known tech firm in our town. Our encounter was briefing.
He was nice to me.
He even apologized for how our relationship soured and wished me all the best.
It it's been four days since I saw him. And honestly, I just get angrier.
The more I think about it,
I gave the 10 best years of my life to this man and got nothing from it.
We never had kids. He never had much money. When we divorce.
I started from square one. Now he's Mr. Successful. While I'm struggling.
My job is very stressful and I'm making less than I was for years ago.
I live alone and money is tight. I've been having some intestinal,
digestive issues and doctors don't seem to know what's wrong with
me. I guess.
I just wanna know why he couldn't have been better to me and why I was never
worth the effort that it, oh.
That was not love. That was a in Jackson. I can't really put the finger on it,
but you are mad because he's
in a better place, man. I does not.
Love. Well,
she's wondering why he couldn't have been in a better place when they were
together. Cause these things.
Take time. You left. You decided to end in relationship. That's what you said.
Well, they were married for 10 years. I'm not saying no 10 years still 10.
Years is a long time. 10 years is a long time for someone to be up. Yeah, it is.
Do you think somebody's gonna stay with somebody who's up for 10 years,
expecting them to turn it around 10 years.
I'm not expecting that, but I mean you got married in the vow.
It says for better of a worse. That is the worst.
That's how mean I took the vow. I'm you did.
It's an engagement that you have with someone,
maybe it lost its sense and it lost what it means.
Or maybe I'm being too literal with this. Yes. 10 years is a lot.
But when you say for better or for worse, that's the worst.
That is part of it. It could have been worse than that. That's the part of it.
I understand why she left. I get it.
You knew what you were getting yourself into when you married the dude in the
first place, did she? I don't know.
Maybe that's not what she was ever tell.
There's plenty of people who get into a marriage thinking it's one thing.
Then they get married. People get comfortable and they take everything for.
Granted. It's possible. You know what? I'm gonna give it to you.
We don't know fair. But you walk out.
He feels better. You're mad because he feels better. That shouldn't.
Be me. I don't think she's mad that he, he feels better.
She's mad that she was hoping he would do all those things while they were
together.
And it seems like the moment she's out the picture now he's doing all the things
that she wished he would've done.
The human brain is really weird to function.
It takes weird slap in the face for you to realize,
okay, maybe you were enabling him. I don't know.
I was not in the relationship you leaving him was maybe the thing that he needed
to get off his, you were there. I supported him.
I supported him and <inaudible> I gave and I gave and I gave maybe that's what
it was. Maybe he needed you to get the out of there.
Sometimes you need to reach bottom of the barrel rock bought on
Peter deep. You need to reach the bottom bottom. Is it logic? No,
it's human. So maybe her leaving was the thing that he needed.
Is it sad? Yeah. Is it unfortunate? Absolutely poor you,
but it is what it is. Entitlement about. That that I'm a I'm uneasy about.
I can't really put my finger on it.
I'll let I'll ponder on that and I'll let you finish. Just go.
I'll come back on that. Let me just think about it.
All right. Here's the truth.
Him changing after you dumped him is not a big surprise.
You were the catalyst potentially,
or maybe something after you was the catalyst,
but you can't hope to be the catalyst and the beneficiary. If you are,
what brings about change? That change may not benefit you.
I'll give you an example. You have kids. They grew up to be adults.
Sometimes they don't learn the importance of responsibility until they leave the
nest. Sometimes they don't develop into real human beings and real adults until
they're out of their parents' home.
Maybe that person needed to leave in order to realize what they
needed to do for themselves to grow.
When you're in a place of comfort where you know, nothing's gonna go wrong,
you don't have too much incentive to change.
So when he was in a comfortable relationship with you, odds are,
he felt like I can be complacent,
cuz I'm always gonna have this girl in my back.
And when that was removed from under him, he had to reassess some things.
Second thing that strikes me is that I'll try to put this in business terms when
you invest in a company and it goes nowhere. Like what he said earlier,
it's your choice to invest in that company.
You pull out and then after you pull out,
the investment takes off and the company takes off. Well, boo, boo,
you already sold your shares. It's over, that's your cut investment.
You don't get a return on investment, but that was business.
When it comes to people, I feel like it's very similar. You know,
at the end of the day, what he's said, wasn't totally off.
When you marry somebody,
you marry them as they are because you grow doesn't mean someone's gonna grow at
the same rate as you, right? You said something I said was interesting,
which was when we met toge. When we got together, things were great,
but I grew past him and he never grew up. Even to his thirties.
He kept all these bad habits.
Your speed of growth may not be his speed of growth, all grow differently.
And so the fact that he didn't grow at your pace, that's the reality.
I have friends from high school who I love,
but the reality is we grew apart cuz they didn't grow at the same pace or in
different directions than I did.
Mm-hmm <affirmative> I'm not gonna look at them like why haven't you guys joined
me in this? They have their journey.
It's not a race. It's a matter on how long can Mel last.
People can grow apart. And that's a normal process.
That process doesn't mean that one person messed up or the other one did it.
We all have our journeys. Even within relationships. That's a reality. He's 37.
You're 34. So I bet you guys got married when you were around 24 and 27.
That's young, too young, too young professionally.
We're not established as adults and human beings.
We're not completely sure of who we are yet for you guys to get married that
young and be surprised that you're growing apart. It's not surprising to me.
Right? So that's the other thing to consider.
And the last thing is your unhappiness with your current situation has nothing
to do with him. If you're in a relationship, you come mad of it.
You have all this time afterwards and things don't go well or go the way that
you want. And you see they're going well for him. And you're like,
what happened? Why did you boo boo? You should be focused on your situation.
And if your situation was better,
I would guarantee you wouldn't be mad at the progress that he made in his life.
You mad cuz you didn't do everything that you needed to do to set yourself up.
And now you are looking for outside excuses for why your circumstances suck so
much. Oh, this guy, I couldn't believe he did this to me.
Why is he doing better now? That's selfish. Comparing.
Yourself.
That's selfish. If you aren't in a good place, that's your fault.
If you, after 3, 4,
5 years of marriages done now and you haven't gone to a better place,
that's your you're bitter. You're angry.
And you're seeing somebody who used to be beneath you,
be ahead of you by your own standards.
And you're mad cuz you could have had a piece of that. It's entitlement.
You left cuz you didn't want to date down
if we want to be super petty. Yeah. That's what it is.
But now that he caught up to you and surpassed you now,
he doesn't want to be in the same position you were in. Maybe that's what it is.
That's what bother bothers me. You left cuz you dated down.
He surpassed you. And he is like, Hey, well, uh, sorry about before. Uh,
no hard feelings I'm out. He wouldn't do that.
You're because he took the same position that you did.
He's at the position where, when you left that.
He's the ideal man. You would've wanted for your dream life.
And you're realizing you missed out on that. But, and you know,
there's something else that she said that was interesting. She said, I,
I gave them 10 best years of my life.
Mm-hmm <affirmative> meaning she already feels like she's passed her prime.
Well that's how society makes women feel.
Sure. But that's how she also feels. Yeah.
I know women who are in their mid thirties who feel great about themselves.
Oh yeah. So that's not an excuse. It's not right.
And so if you are thinking that way then of course you're not gonna attract
anything positive. Boom. You have the ability to change a lot.
You know, we live in a place where women can make just as much as men,
you guys can do the work. You guys can create your own opportunities.
You could ask men out, you can do all this stuff.
If your life is not going the way you wanted to,
it's not because your ex was a dead it's because it's your fault.
The fact that you stayed with him for 10 years, that it's your fault.
The fact that you're bitter right now, that's your fault. All this to say,
there's no point in wallowing in this.
And the fact that you're angry about it is you're not angry at him.
You're angry at yourself for not doing what you needed to do. There's something.
To set yourself up. There's something unhealthy about that.
About being angry about it, her and being angry at of course she's bitter,
yo man, bitter about life.
Only somebody who's bitter about life would get mad that an X is doing well.
Concentrate on yourself. Yeah. Be stay focused. Be yeah.
Even if you wasted a lot of years with you,
you decided to stay in that relationship. You should have cut bait way earlier.
When you focus on yourself,
you're in competition with people that you don't even know you're in competition
with. And now youre in that position,
he doesn't even know he's a competition.
He's just that ex and he's sorry about what he did before.
Focus. So if you got bitter feelings about your ex,
if somebody you left started doing way better and you're like, oh my God,
I'm stop. Just focus on your own stuff. Do better for yourself.
I had a girl who did that to me.
She was upset that I got my together.
She got upset that you got your together. Say that.
Again. Here's the thing. Right? She got.
Upset that you got your.
Together. So when I wasn't doing much had no money, my name,
nothing else, she didn't think it was a good prospect.
Then I started figuring stuff out and she's like, oh, are you really coming?
And she tried to slide back in, you know what I'm saying? And I was like, nah,
I don't need none of that. But I just remember her being like, man,
I wish it would've been like this a couple years back. And I was like, no,
it would took me this whole journey to get to this place. It took me this long.
It took me my results. Didn't just come here it take. That's it. You know?
So you gotta work on that. I mean, I didn't get mad about it, but yeah.
So all this to say guys, men or women just don't be bitter. It really doesn't.
Do you any justice? And if you're feeling angry about something like that,
you don't have to beat yourself up over. It just don't give it energy.
It's not real. Unless you start doing stuff about it. All right.
You got a little bit of ego. Your ego's bruised. Keep moving,
start working on stuff. It'll pass. Give you.
More power to work on you. Exactly.
I hope it gives you more fuel to work on you because
girl staying and dwelling on that. It's not gonna your predicament,
but whatever.
So tell us what you guys think in the comments below.
We want to hear your input. What do you guys think about this story?